This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. We are a culture fascinated with style. There always seems to be some awards ceremony or gala where people are talking about what everyone is wearing. And it seems like it's always fashion week somewhere, am I right? Every truffleman, living every week, like it's fashion week. And there are street style blogs and festival fashion roundups and then out of the sidewalks and the catwalks, a style emerges. And then it comes time for the mass market to get the look,
这里是《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。我们是一个痴迷于时尚的文化。似乎总有一些颁奖典礼或晚宴，人们在谈论每个人穿了什么。而且好像无论在哪里，总有那么一周是时装周，对吧？每个特鲁夫曼（Truffleman），每周都过得像时装周一样。街头风格博客、节日时尚盘点层出不穷，然后从人行道和T台上，一种风格便应运而生。接着，大众市场就开始追求这种造型了，
which might mean graphic t-shirts are hot right now, or cobalt blue or minimalism or platform sneakers. And you might be saying to yourself, trends are for trendy people. I follow nerd stuff like podcasts. I don't follow trends. They might say that, but they do. They're lying.
这可能意味着印花T恤现在很火，或者是钴蓝色、极简主义，又或者是厚底运动鞋。你可能会对自己说，潮流是给赶时髦的人准备的。我只关注像播客这样的极客内容。我不追潮流。他们可能会这么说，但他们其实是在追。他们在撒谎。
Ha, ha, ha, ha. Professor Sarah Pettit, calling everyone's bluff. Kind of. They're not outright lying. They just don't realize what they're doing. Professor Pettit is coordinator of the Fabric styling program at the Fashion Institute of Technology in New York. You might not realize it, but subconsciously.
哈哈哈哈。萨拉·佩蒂特（Sarah Pettit）教授，揭穿了所有人的虚张声势。某种程度上是这样。他们不是公然撒谎。他们只是没有意识到自己在做什么。佩蒂特教授是纽约时装技术学院（FIT）面料造型项目的协调员。你可能没意识到，但在潜意识里，
You can kind of tell when styles are shifting. You may not think that what you have on is jaded, but this other thing suddenly may look new to you, and it's all over all the windows, it's all over all the racks, and you probably would get influenced by that. Don't you think so? Whether or not you consciously notice it, the trend cycle is circling all around you. And it's moving fast. It's not like we just have a spring fashion season and a fall fashion season. There's now a steady turnover of styles.
你其实能感觉到风格何时在转变。你可能不觉得你身上穿的已经过时了，但另一件东西突然看起来可能很新颖，而且它出现在所有的橱窗里，挂在所有的货架上，你很可能会受到影响。你不觉得吗？无论你是否有意察觉，潮流周期都在你周围循环。而且它移动得很快。并不是说我们只有春季时装季和秋季时装季。现在风格的更迭非常稳定。
If you go to certain stores like H&M, they change the line maybe every two weeks, because every how many clothes to any of us really need. They have to get us to throw our clothes out so that we buy new things. This creates manufacturing, this creates sales, and it makes the monetary retail world go round. This creates manufacturing, this creates sales, and it makes the monetary retail world go round.
如果你去H&M这样的商店，他们可能每两周就会更换一次产品线，因为我们每个人到底需要多少衣服呢？他们必须让我们扔掉旧衣服，这样我们才会买新的。这创造了制造业，创造了销售额，并让货币化的零售世界运转起来。这创造了制造业，创造了销售额，并让货币化的零售世界运转起来。
And it's not just clothes, it's our homeware, our linens, our car, whatever. Our tastes are constantly made to change. Color is that kind of change. Like sharp truths may come in every five years or so. Purple can be big one year, and then it takes about five years to come around again. Most trends are cyclical. The question is about timing,
而且不仅仅是衣服，还有我们的家居用品、床品、汽车等等。我们的品味被不断地改变。颜色就是这种变化的一种。比如鲜艳的色彩可能每五年左右流行一次。紫色可能某一年很火，然后大约需要五年时间才会再次流行。大多数潮流都是周期性的。问题在于时机，
about when it's time for a trend to come back around again. And to get their timing right, a lot of designers and retailers and fashion students turn to one major company. People use WGSN, yes, as a school we have access to WGSN. WGSN. Which sounds more like the name of a radio station. From WGSN, 90.7, your 24-hour Christian companion.
关于潮流何时回归的时机。为了把握好时机，许多设计师、零售商和时装专业的学生都会求助于一家大公司。人们使用WGSN，是的，作为学校，我们有权访问WGSN。WGSN。听起来更像是一个电台的名字。来自WGSN 90.7，您24小时的基督教伴侣。
It is indeed a radio station in Tennessee, but that is not the WGSN we're talking about. WGSN is the company that might have determined what you are wearing right now. And I'd never heard of it. A lot of people haven't actually. It's a little bit of an industry secret in a way. This is Sarah Owen, a forecaster at WGSN, which is a global trend forecasting agency. There are other trend forecasters and trend forecasting companies, but WGSN is the most influential. We have been around for 18 years, we're in over 94 countries in terms of clients, and
它确实是田纳西州的一个电台，但那不是我们所说的WGSN。WGSN是一家可能已经决定了你现在穿什么的机构。我以前从未听说过它。实际上很多人都没听说过。在某种程度上，它是行业内的一个小秘密。这是萨拉·欧文（Sarah Owen），WGSN的一名预测员，这是一家全球潮流预测机构。还有其他的潮流预测员和潮流预测公司，但WGSN是最具影响力的。我们已经存在18年了，我们的客户遍布94个国家，而且
around 6000 companies subscribe to us. And what does WGSN stand for? This is why I'm not sure why, because it used to be worth global style network. Worth as in Mark Worth, who founded the company in 1997. But after he sold WGSN, it was called World Global Style Network. But mostly it's just called WGSN. So I think it's kind of become an acronym that doesn't really have a meaning?
大约有6000家公司订阅了我们的服务。WGSN代表什么？这就是为什么我不确定原因，因为它曾经是“Worth全球风格网络”（Worth Global Style Network）。Worth指的是1997年创立该公司的马克·沃斯（Mark Worth）。但在他卖掉WGSN后，它被称为“世界全球风格网络”（World Global Style Network）。但大多数时候它就叫WGSN。所以我认为它已经变成了一个没有实际含义的缩写？
And WGSN is part publishing platform, GSN. So I think it's kind of become an acronym that doesn't really have a meaning. And WGSN is part publishing platform, part fashion house, part research company, and what they provide is a comprehensive website behind an extremely steep paywall, like tens of thousands of dollars, depending on the size of the company and the subscription level. But pretty much every major manufacturer designed studio and marketing company subscribes to it. And we have clients across all industries, not just retail in the fashion space. So a few of our clients range from fashion companies
WGSN既是一个出版平台，也是一个时尚屋，还是一个研究公司，他们提供的是一个设置了极高付费墙的综合网站，费用高达数万美元，具体取决于公司规模和订阅级别。但几乎每一家大型制造商、设计工作室和营销公司都订阅了它。我们的客户遍布所有行业，不仅仅是时尚零售领域。所以我们的一些客户范围从时尚公司，
such as Nike and Coach and H&M to food and beverage companies like Starbucks, to TV networks like NBC and Nickelodeon. So it's quite varied. WGSN reports on all kinds of trends, including behavior patterns, consumption patterns, and advertising predictions. But the majority of their users are coming at it from the design side. So if you are a designer, a colorist, or merchandiser for a major company or brand, you'd
比如耐克（Nike）、蔻驰（Coach）和H&M，到星巴克（Starbucks）这样的食品和饮料公司，再到NBC和尼克儿童频道（Nickelodeon）这样的电视网络。所以范围非常广泛。WGSN报道各种潮流，包括行为模式、消费模式和广告预测。但他们的大多数用户是从设计端切入的。所以如果你是一名设计师、配色师或大型公司或品牌的商品企划，你会
consult WGSN to figure out what colors will be in and what styles are ahead. And whether designers heed this advice or not, it's considered essential to at least know what WGSN is saying, because they're commenting on trends they notice in a really in-depth way. So there's that level of analysis that you just can't find, and people actually just don't have the time to do themselves. And to keep ahead of the trend cycle, WGSN predicts two years in advance. That's as long as we can really look ahead with our qualitative and quantitative analysis
咨询WGSN以弄清楚哪些颜色会流行，哪些风格即将到来。无论设计师是否听从这些建议，了解WGSN的说法都被认为是必不可少的，因为他们以非常深入的方式评论他们注意到的趋势。所以那种分析水平是你无法找到的，而且人们实际上也没有时间自己去做。为了保持在潮流周期的前沿，WGSN会提前两年进行预测。这是我们通过定性和定量分析所能展望的最长时间，
further out than that and it's really quiet. It's speculating. Guestimation, as you want to say. But honestly, I had a really hard time wrapping my head around WGSN and what they offer until Sarah let me take a peek at the site. It is a website behind a paywall. A really beautiful, sleek website. It almost looked like an upscale online store, but then when you click a category, it looks
再往后看就真的很模糊了。这是推测。用你想说的话，就是“估测”。但老实说，在萨拉让我看一眼网站之前，我真的很难理解WGSN及其提供的服务。这是一个有付费墙的网站。一个非常漂亮、时尚的网站。它看起来几乎像是一个高端在线商店，但当你点击一个类别时，它看起来
more like a Pinterest page, just loaded with pictures. So we have catwalks, images, high resolution, all of those, original images for street style, for trade shows, for denim. In addition to all the photography of models and festival goers and beautiful stylish people, there are articles and reports organized by category. All the fashion categories from accessories to beauty, footwear, kids wear, women's wear youth. What is denim get its own category? It's a huge market. This is denim senior editor, denim director, too. I think denim associate editors, the editors are working on articles
更像是一个Pinterest页面，上面全是图片。所以我们有T台图片、高分辨率图片、所有这些，还有街头风格、贸易展、牛仔布的原始图片。除了所有模特、节日参与者和时尚人士的照片外，还有按类别组织的各种文章和报告。涵盖了从配饰到美容、鞋类、童装、女装、青年装等所有时尚类别。为什么牛仔布有自己的类别？这是一个巨大的市场。这是牛仔布高级编辑，也是牛仔布总监。我想牛仔布副编辑们，编辑们正在撰写文章，
that not only find the trends, but explain them. Because we do work so far in an event, I did do a report close to two years ago. It was called the New Young Contemporary. This report, Sarah, did on the New Young Contemporary was about the next generation of consumers. Gen Z. Your Gen Z is your teenager. She's about to go back to school. She's back to school shopping. She's still going to festivals.
不仅要发现趋势，还要解释它们。因为我们的工作非常超前，我确实在近两年前做过一份报告。它被称为“新年轻当代”（New Young Contemporary）。萨拉关于“新年轻当代”的这份报告是关于下一代消费者的。Z世代。你的Z世代就是你的青少年。她快要回学校了。她正在进行返校购物。她仍然会去参加音乐节。
She lives at home. She's obviously a digital native, multi-screen personality. And Sarah's report found that Gen Z's idols are fashion models, not movie actresses. And so these models are on Instagram and in magazines, wearing couture on the runways. And this makes the members of Gen Z want access to high fashion. This consumer base is really being primed to be the next luxury consumer. And so that's clearly come to fruition now. It seems super relevant, but two years ago it was kind of still a testing idea with some retailers.
她住在家里。她显然是数字原住民，拥有多屏人格。萨拉的报告发现，Z世代的偶像是时尚模特，而不是电影女演员。所以这些模特出现在Instagram和杂志上，在T台上穿着高级定制服装。这使得Z世代的成员想要获得高级时装。这个消费群体确实正在被培养成为下一代奢侈品消费者。所以这显然现在已经实现了。这看起来超级相关，但在两年前，这对于一些零售商来说还是一种处于测试阶段的想法。
And other researchers at WGSN are already preparing for the next wave of consumers after Gen Z. Generation Alpha, I think, that the newest, that the ones under Gen Z. Welcome to a relevant scene, millennials. In addition to the reports and the images, WGSN has this really fascinating component that makes it very, very different from a journalism site or a fashion blog.
WGSN的其他研究人员已经在为Z世代之后的下一波消费者做准备了。阿尔法世代（Generation Alpha），我想，那是最新的，Z世代之后的那些人。欢迎来到相关场景，千禧一代。除了报告和图片，WGSN还有一个非常迷人的组件，这使得它与新闻网站或时尚博客非常、非常不同。
They have a database full of colors, patterns, and 71,000 original design templates for design teams to just use, however they want. So there really is a lot that you can take as a designer, open it in Illustrator, Photoshop, and rework it, however works for your customer. You'll get embellishments and trims and you have prints and graphics and clip art there as well. If you wanted to make, say, a shirt, you could choose a template, maybe add a pocket
他们有一个充满颜色、图案和71,000个原始设计模板的数据库，供设计团队随意使用。所以作为设计师，你确实可以拿走很多东西，在Illustrator、Photoshop中打开它，并根据你的客户需求进行修改。你还可以获得装饰品、饰边，以及印花、图形和剪贴画。如果你想制作，比如说，一件衬衫，你可以选择一个模板，也许加一个口袋，
or something, select a color swatch or pattern that WGSN says will be popular two years into the future. And voila, there's your design. Oh my God. So these are, these are jeans for 2018. Oh my God. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. What do jeans of 2018 look like? Oh, I kind of can't tell you because WGSN is very protective of this information. And rightfully so, people pay a lot of money for it.
或者其他什么，选择一个WGSN认为在两年后会流行的色卡或图案。瞧，这就是你的设计。天哪。所以这些是2018年的牛仔裤。天哪。哇，哇，哇，哇。2018年的牛仔裤长什么样？哦，我有点不能告诉你，因为WGSN对这些信息非常保密。理应如此，人们为此支付了高昂的费用。
This precious intel makes it fast and easy for design teams to come up with new styles. Someone argue. Too easy. Mark Worth himself, the founder of WGSN, sold the company in 2005. According to the independent, Worth called his creation a monster, saying, quote, shoppers complain that everything on the high street looks the same. But is it any wonder? Instead of looking for inspiration, brands are lying on templates.
这些宝贵的情报使设计团队能够快速、轻松地构思出新的风格。有人会争辩说，太容易了。WGSN的创始人马克·沃斯本人在2005年卖掉了公司。据《独立报》报道，沃斯称他的创造是一个“怪物”，他说：“购物者抱怨大街上的东西看起来都一样。但这有什么好奇怪的呢？品牌不再寻找灵感，而是依赖模板。”
And because everyone uses the same templates, there's no competitive edge. End quote. Whether it was an adherence to an ideology of creativity and competition, or just an opportunity to build another business and sell it off again for tons of money, Mark Worth started a rival forecasting company called Stylus. It's a much smaller company with two offices and about 400 clients, and it doesn't have all the templates and ready-made designs. We don't tend to have like downloadable prints and patterns and things like that because fashion is just kind of one element of what we do.
“而且因为每个人都使用相同的模板，所以没有竞争优势。”引用结束。无论是因为坚持创造力和竞争的意识形态，还是仅仅为了建立另一家企业并再次高价卖出，马克·沃斯创办了一家名为Stylus的竞争对手预测公司。这是一家规模小得多的公司，有两个办公室和大约400个客户，而且它没有所有的模板和现成的设计。我们通常没有那种可下载的印花、图案之类的东西，因为时尚只是我们所做工作的一个要素。
That's Shannon Davenport, a forecaster at Stylis in their New York office. Stylis is also a website behind a paywall, and they can view all of the content. They have a client services person to help them. So if somebody says, I'm doing a piece of research on the future of breakfast. Our client service person goes in and says, here's a really interesting piece of work that we did about fluid life styles and about people multitasking. And this could affect the future of breakfast. The future of breakfast. Oh man. No, but really, there are trends for breakfast
那是香农·达文波特（Shannon Davenport），Stylus纽约办公室的一名预测员。Stylus也是一个有付费墙的网站，他们可以查看所有内容。他们有专门的客户服务人员来帮助他们。所以如果有人说，我正在做一份关于早餐未来的研究。我们的客户服务人员会进去说，这是我们做的关于流动生活方式和人们多任务处理的一项非常有趣的工作。这可能会影响早餐的未来。早餐的未来。天哪。不，但真的，早餐也有潮流，
and stylists will say to the client. Here's what we saw something interesting from our packaging team about new on-the-go packaging, which seems silly, but that is really the kind of stuff that often clients have to think about and wrap their heads around. Trend forecasting is not just about taste or aesthetics. Trends also take changes in lifestyle into account. So WGSN and stylists also work with stats and projections, like this one.
Stylus会告诉客户。这是我们从包装团队那里看到的关于新型便携包装的一些有趣的东西，这看起来很傻，但这确实是客户经常需要思考和理解的事情。潮流预测不仅仅关乎品味或美学。潮流也考虑到了生活方式的变化。所以WGSN和Stylus也使用统计数据和预测，比如这个。
40% of Americans will work from home by 2020, so I just start to like throw some questions around my head. I'm like, okay, so if everyone's working from home, a sweatpants back in style. That's Sarah Owen again from WGSN. Turns out yes, sweatpants are back in the trend cycle, but like cool looking sweatpants that you could also wear to a bar. Both WGSN and stylists say there's a rise
到2020年，40%的美国人将在家工作，所以我开始在脑子里抛出一些问题。我想，好吧，如果每个人都在家工作，运动裤是不是又流行回来了？那是WGSN的萨拉·欧文。事实证明，是的，运动裤又回到了潮流周期中，但那是看起来很酷的运动裤，你也可以穿着去酒吧。WGSN和Stylus都表示，
in what they call the at-leisure style of clothing, which looks good at home on the couch in the office or out at night. To me, it's connecting the dogs, it's pattern recognition, it's taking those cues and pairing that with that data and they will kind of inform the future. Oh, create it, that's out. Tagline. Create tomorrow is actually written in huge neon letters in WGSN's New York office, which is, I don't know, it's kind of strange to see. It made me wonder if WGSN was catering to my tastes or actually creating them for me. They have such a strong influence in the industry. I can't tell if they're reporting trends or dictating them. Yeah, that's always so hard, because like I said, we do have some of the most influential
他们所说的“休闲运动风”（at-leisure）服装正在兴起，这种服装在家里沙发上、办公室里或晚上外出时看起来都很不错。对我来说，这是在连接点，是模式识别，是获取这些线索并将其与数据配对，它们会以某种方式预示未来。哦，创造它，那是我们的口号。“创造明天”（Create tomorrow）实际上是用巨大的霓虹灯字母写在WGSN纽约办公室里的，这，我不知道，看起来有点奇怪。这让我怀疑WGSN是在迎合我的品味，还是实际上在为我创造品味。他们在行业中拥有如此强大的影响力。我无法分辨他们是在报道潮流还是在支配潮流。是的，这总是很难，因为就像我说的，我们确实拥有世界上一些最具影响力、
and recognizable brands in the world using us, so it's like, did we create it or was it actually about to come to fruition? Shannon at Stylus told me that even paint companies and textile manufacturers were using their trend forecasting services to decide what fabrics and colors to make, which then informed the trends that stylus puts out. At some point you just lose track of who is influencing whom. But ultimately the buck stops with us, the consumer. What's the thing you can lead a horse to water or something, but you can't make them drink? Professor Sarah Pettit again.
最知名的品牌在使用我们，所以就像是，是我们创造了它，还是它实际上即将实现？Stylus的香农告诉我，甚至油漆公司和纺织品制造商也在使用他们的潮流预测服务来决定生产什么面料和颜色，这反过来又影响了Stylus发布的潮流。在某种程度上，你只是失去了对谁在影响谁的追踪。但最终，责任在于我们，消费者。那句话怎么说来着，你可以把马牵到水边，但你不能强迫它喝水？还是佩蒂特教授。
You can show them things that are very far out, things that you think they should buy, but if it's something that's not gonna work, they're not gonna do it. For example, Professor Pettit says there was a movement recently to bring back the mini skirt. They thought, okay, it hasn't been around a while, and for the new generation of young kids,
你可以向他们展示非常前卫的东西，你认为他们应该买的东西，但如果这是行不通的东西，他们就不会买。例如，佩蒂特教授说，最近有一场让迷你裙回归的运动。他们想，好吧，它已经有一段时间没流行了，对于新一代的年轻人来说，
let's try to reintroduce this. It flopped totally. So if people really don't want it, it's going to flop. The consumer has a voice in this, and it's a very active voice. And lately it seems there's been a great refusal of sorts, a massive backlash against fast fashion and trends themselves. It's interesting we've come off this kind of phase in fashion of trends changing really fast. A lot of design today is focused on simplicity, minimalism and quality.
让我们试着重新引入它。结果彻底失败了。所以如果人们真的不想要它，它就会失败。消费者在这方面有发言权，而且是一个非常积极的发言权。最近似乎出现了一种巨大的拒绝，对快时尚和潮流本身的大规模抵制。有趣的是，我们已经走出了时尚界潮流更迭非常快的阶段。今天很多设计都专注于简洁、极简主义和质量。
Even with with fashion, which for a long time was super, super trend driven, that people are starting to think more about basics. So more of having that great pair of jeans that they can wear with everything. But Shannon seemed remarkably calm as she told me about this change in the tides. She does not think the trend industry is doomed. So it's not like simplicity means that people are just completely not shopping and you know, everybody's is like becoming, you know, anti-consumerism. God forbid.
即使是时尚，长期以来一直是非常、非常受潮流驱动的，人们也开始更多地考虑基础款。所以更多的是拥有一条可以搭配一切的优质牛仔裤。但香农在告诉我这种潮流转变时显得非常冷静。她不认为潮流行业注定要失败。所以并不是说简洁意味着人们完全不购物，你知道，每个人都变得，你知道，反消费主义了。上帝保佑。
It's just that the things that made people buy before are changing. I was gonna say, the trend is that there are fewer trends, but maybe that is also a trend. Yeah. Well, I mean, there's actually been a really interesting shift, but it's not to say that it's not going to shift again. It's hard to say, but let's just check back here in two years. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Avery Truffman with Katie Mingle's Sam Greenspan Kurt Colstead and it fits Gerald Taren Mazza, Sherefusef, and me Roman Mars.
只是以前促使人们购买的东西正在改变。我正想说，潮流就是潮流变少了，但也许这也是一种潮流。是的。嗯，我的意思是，实际上发生了一个非常有趣的转变，但这并不是说它不会再次转变。很难说，但让我们两年后再来看看。本周的《99%隐形》由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffman）制作，凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）、萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）、库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）以及菲茨·杰拉德（Fitz Gerald）、塔伦·马扎（Taren Mazza）、谢尔·尤瑟夫（Sheref Yusef）和我罗曼·马斯共同参与。
Special thanks to Kara Rose DeFabio of, without the article she wrote about WGSN, we would not have known this company exists. We'll have a link to that article on our website. We are a project of 91.7 KALW San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and join the discussions about this show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars or the show at 99PI.org. We're on Instagram and don't learn too. But the Nexus of all things 99PI is at 99PI.org.
特别感谢卡拉·罗斯·德法比奥（Kara Rose DeFabio），没有她写的关于WGSN的文章，我们就不会知道这家公司的存在。我们会在网站上提供那篇文章的链接。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心“广播街”（Radio Row）制作。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与关于这个节目的讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，或者关注节目@99PI.org。我们在Instagram上也有账号。但所有99PI相关事物的核心都在99PI.org。
Radio to PI. Radio Tepi-U from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Radio to PI。来自PRX的Radio Tepi-U。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。